[موسيقى]
الله
هنا العاصمه العراقيه بغداد
يتميز العراق بتنوع ثقافته حيث يتكون
المجتمع العراقي من طوائف
عديده
لاسباب او لاخرى ونتيجه السياسه معينه
يتضائل افراد بعض الديانات والطوائف حتى
شرفت على الزوال ويتعرض افرض بعض الديانات
الى الكثير من الصعاب ما يشكل تحديا
للبقاء في بلد نحرته الصراعاته على مدى
عقود عديده
هنا هو المعبد الرئيسي للمنديين الذين
يقدروا عددهم من 30 الى 50 الف سنه يعيشون
في العراق نرحل بكم عبر عدسه مهمه خاصه
لنوريكم عاداتهم وتقاليدهم وطقوسهم
الدينيه التي توالتوها عن مشايخهم على مر
الزمان
وينسبون دينهم الى النبي ادم عليه السلام
[موسيقى]
جذورها الى الاف السنين الى عهد ابونا ادم
راس الذريه
نشات هذه الديانه في مدينه في جنوب العراق
في مدينه ميشان ميشان حاليا يؤمن الصبي
المندائيون باله واحد انبعث من ذاته وان
بعثه الحياه منه
ليس له بدايه وليس له نهايه في كتابنا
المبارك
الصحف الاولى التي انزلت هذه الصحف على
ادم والشتاء ابن ادم وادريس او دنا الاخت
النبي ادريس
وشومبر انه سام ابن نوح وهي برجال يحيى بن
زكريا عليهم وعلى كل الانبياء السلام هذه
الصحائف انزلت عليهم من قبل الميلاد جبريل
نحن نسميه جبرائيل لها جبرائيل يعني
جبرائيل فيها الرسول الرسول جبرائيل وهو
واهب كلمات النور من هالحين العظيم الى
ادم وذريته من بعده